hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of our readers lalitha who
asked about one of my favorite serves is
to use odesk so she is an online
marketer she does a lot of article
submissions and has an e-book and other
programs that she wants to promote which
is a lot of social media marketing and
she's wondering if somebody could help
her on odesk to reduce some of those
admin tasks for her so she's wondering
what category she should post a job
under and any other thoughts I might
have to help her out soul aletha i would
suggest posting under the administrative
support category there's tons of people
who can help you with that kind of stuff
that's bread and butter odesk really
easy to find somebody to help you out
you don't have to worry about hiring
somebody full time they could do it for
part-time hours they're used to that
they're set up there there to support
people who want to do online marketing
so it's a great fit for the type of
tasks you have as long as you can really
be clear about what it is that you need
and give them a little bit of training
on how to how to log into your accounts
and all that in terms of posting a job i
would suggest again put under the
admin's apport category in my job
postings I always try to ask a question
that they have to include with their
profile so I might write a really long
paragraph and then if you if you have
some social media accounts might ask
them to say something like post how many
Twitter followers I have four how many
Facebook Likes I have so that you make
sure when they give you their submission
they've actually read your entire job
application so make sure you do that the
next thing usually do is I hire people
on a trial basis so I can set up a trial
job give them a simple task see if they
do it see if it's accurate see if it's
easy working with them and then from
there make a decision as to who to hire
and then even after I make that hiring
decision I'll usually hire more than one
person and just cut back the number of
hours you can say I need somebody for
five hours a week or even less if you
need that and hire a couple people and
the cream will rise to the top you'll
find that you know one or two people are
really really really good and the others
might fall off a little bit so it helps
you work with a couple people to make
sure you get in the right person but
big fan of audacity have hired a number
of people through it and it's been a
huge boost for my business lets me focus
on the bigger picture stuff for my
company and can outsource the other
stuff to people who want to do and who
are good at it and probably better than
me at it as well so I hope that helps if
you guys liked the video please give it
a thumbs up below and I'd also love to
hear feedback if you want to leave a
comment underneath the video and stay
tuned to the next episode
you